once again here are the latest poll
between President Obama and President
Trump
hello
Barack so cubby what is mood light
anyway coming-of-age story about a young
gay black man wait a minute he's gay and
black I didn't know you could be both
hello a barrette I've just drawn a zero
feel free to do that on email they just
like a butor away who did the FBI CIA I
don't know they were so junk guys you
sure work with your thumbs sort of it
I'm in a real day I don't know who
anybody is
okay well is there anything I can help
you with who is this again
Ava Rach hey did you see steam baton and
Royce poor bus at a joint press
conference you mean Reince Priebus yeah
whatever and take a goddamn Star Wars
name or something anyway stay tuned that
their fighting starts getting along fine
whatever you say oh crap gotta go
Santa's got roads in a headlock
hello a drag what does not much Donald
what do you need
I was just wondering if you saw that i
rescinded your bill allowing
transformers to use in the been pretty
great right Donald that's not what you
did the law wasn't about transformers it
was to protect transgender people from
discrimination
what no that'd told me it would just
people were about guys for being in a
bear
have you read any of the papers even
signing oh god go
hello MARAC I have a question for you
what is it which one of these dick tapes
is your favorite but Rock Me Amadeus the
way in for a suggestion I want to rock
with you Detroit barracks city barracks
Paper Scissors use ferocity all night
long for rock and roll
coochie-coo Barack story Nicolas Cage
and Sean Connery
[Applause]
you